みなさん、ここでローガンします。今日は
ananyaに参加しました
。ananyaが
戻ってきて、チャンネルに戻ってきてくれてありがとう。これは
、文字通り日本の学習コミュニティの伝説になっていることを光栄に思います。
本当に感謝していますそうそう
私たちが最初の会話でこれについて話したのは完全に私の喜び
です私が
フォローしている誰かがあなたのビデオの1つまたは
Twitterの何かを好きだったのでそれは
私のTwitterフィードに表示され、私はそれを見ましたそして私
はそれがあったと思います あなたが本当に
好きだったブリトー私はそれを見ました私はええええのようでした
そして私はああ私の神のようでしたこれは
特にええとええと
あなたがその行を知っ
ているようにとても面白いですええ
戦利品を使った経験のないビデオを書くことはできなかったので、
いわばあなたの視点を聞くのは面白い
です。あなたが将来作る予定のコンセプトにとても興奮していますが、
行く前に 遠すぎる その道は
、基本的な
自己紹介のように
、あなたが生まれた場所のように、日本の漫画を勉強する方法を教えたいと
思いますか？
それ
が私の起源でした私は本当に若い頃にインドで
生まれました6
ヶ月で生まれたように私たちは州に移りました
そして私は6歳になるまで
東海岸に
住んでいました カリフォルニアでは、
日本は私の
人生のかなりの部分で私のようにまったくレーダーに載っていなかったので、ベイエリア
は
12歳か13歳だったと思います。
マンガかええ当然マンガは
私に話しかけたようなもので、私の
夢は中学生のときにマンガ家になりたいと思っていた
ようなものでした。
さて、私は本当に
楽しみの
ためにあなたから始めたように日本語を学びたいです 私はtofuguに行きまし
たが、それはおそらくtofugu Japanesepod101のような私の主な情報源であり、
すべてのアプリを
すべて試しました。
それから私は約8年間日本語を勉強してきましたが
、今
はucを卒業したばかりです。
バークレー
私は日本人とはかなり違うビジネスを勉強
しましたが、日本人と何かをすることに非常に集中していました。
それから
現在、アマゾンでマーケティングを行っています。
日本側でも
少しです。
仕事と学校の間の夏の間にそれをやっていた間、私はコンテンツの
作成を始めましたええと、去年は実際に
ツイッターをやっていて、それから
最近tiktokを始めたので
、たくさんのものに飛び込むのが好きです
私の日本語をそのように
使ってください アートに夢中になっている
あなたは一生、どんなアート
をやってい
たのですか？若い頃はどんなアートをやっていたのですか？ええ
、サンデーコミックのような漫画を描くのが
好き
でした。
マンガ全体を書いた
私はそれのためにスクリプトを書いたそしてそれから私はそれを失ったので私はすべて
の泡とすべてを持っ
ているがそれを埋める物語はないそれはええと最も奇妙な
ものの
ようでした アート私は
日本に関連するものをたくさん描きました。それは
私がそれに強い情熱を表現していたよう
なものでしたが、ええ、
今はあまりアートをしていません。それ
は残念ですが、それは私の目標のようでした。
子供の頃、確かに非常に興味深いものでした
が、
tik tokやtwitterのように、あなたがやっているコメディーのようなものを始めたきっかけは何
でしたか？
あなたがそれを試してみたかった特定の理由y ええ、それは本当に
面白いことです。考えれば考えるほど
、それは非常に深い場所に根ざしているように感じますが、
非常に普通に始まりました。
子供の頃、
私はあまりにも本当に
そうだとは言えませんでし
た。見知らぬ人と話すのが好きになったり
、マクドナルドの従業員の
ように、別のおもちゃやいつものようなものを手に入れたりする必要があるときは言うまでもありませんでした。
もっと外向的でもっと
世に出たいと思っていたので、それを行うためのツールとして日本語を使ったと思います。そういうわけで、
ツイッターでソーシャルメディアにたくさんのことを出そうとしていたようになりました。
テキストベースのコンテンツをたくさんやっていて、
それを少し混ぜたかった
ので、1、2回
思いついた小さなスキットを撮影しました。
それらは本当に
うまくいき、本当に楽しかったです。 組み立てが簡単で
、
それがきっかけだったので、 去年の
11月
は私が始めたときですそしてあなたはii
が本当にひどくティックタックをしたかったのを知っています
そしてそれで私はちょうど
私が持っていたビデオをtiktokに投げました
エアホステスか
トレンドのようなもので、誰も
日本語をやっていませんでした韓国語を
見ました中国人を見
ました ツイッターやどこでもこれまでに得た
よりもはるかに多い20万回以上の視聴回数を
獲得
したので、これはチャンスかもしれないと思っていた
ので、それを
追求し始め
たのです。 ええと、
あなたが
日本語でアートを作りたいと思った理由は、
それがカチカチ音をたてていたのか、それとも
ツイッターでちょっとしたジョークを知っていたのか、
もっと外向的になりたいと思ったからです。
ちょっと無意識だったのかな 芸術
的な表現で自分を表現する方法を探していますえ
えと、
私は
ソーシャルメディアで何かをしたいと思っていたと思い
ます。
本当に日本
と関係があります。
ソーシャルメディアやyoutubeのようなものを
やりたいという願望は、日常生活の中でそれをやらないことと並んで、
明らかに
私が今ツイッターで好きなことをしているように、
そしてそれは本当に私が好きなことのようです。
mとても情熱
的で、それは私がそうすることができるという副次的なもののようなものです
。あなた
の日本人は驚異的であるため、
あなたは正確にあなたが知っている人です。 受講した教室で日本語を勉強したことはありません。
大学への編入が好きなクラスがあると
思いますが、その時点ですでに
5年以上日本語を勉強し
ていて、エレムが好きでした。 当時はケーキウォークの
ようなものでしたが、
どうやって始めたのかを詳しく知ることができます。詳細
を聞きたいのですが、
おそらく私のチャンネルやフォロワーをたくさん見ている人が多いと思い
ます。
また、
あなたが物事をどのように研究したかをより具体的に学びたい
と思います。あなたが過去に作成したビデオで、あなたが日本語で
話すインドの言語との間にいくつかの重複があるとあなたがどのように考えているかについて話している
のを見ました。  d
も聞いてとても面白いです
ええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええええ 日本のポッド101だから私
は彼らのビデオをたくさんチェックしたので私
は人間の日本語とtofuguの無料の部分を使用した
のでそれらは私が向かった3つのリソースの一種です
カタカナとあなた
は最初の1、2ヶ月であなたが知っていることをやめ
、それからそこから
、
文法を学ぶための私の主な情報源
のような日本語を学ぶためのキムのガイドをとどめてください。
毎週のように電話をかける言語の相棒で、私が
最初に始め
たとき、それは間違いなく助けになったと思います。
言語パートナーのように、
とにかく見る場所があまりなかった
ので、それは私が話すことに関して私がしたことでした、
そして私はニコニコナマホソのようにも使用します
それは、日本語
にとってイマージョンが非常に重要だと思う例だと思い
ます。あなたとマットがそのことについて話していることを知っています。イマージョン
は、日本語を正直に学ぶための聖杯だと思います。
私が最初の日本のリソースを購入したとき、
それはカセットテープのようでした。
今のように、
今は
YouTubeにジャンプしたり、netflixにジャンプしたり
して、すぐに無制限の
量の
ネイティブ入力を取得できるように、一般的なダイナミックの点で大きく異なります。
とても貴重なことだと思います。
おそらく、日本人学生になるのにこれほど良い時期はなかったと思い
ます。あなたがこれらの
さまざまなことをどのように活用したかを聞くのは興味深いことです。
YouTubeが物事のようになる前にやったこと、そうですね
、パラダイムがどのように変化したかを見るのは非常に興味深い
ことです。 早い段階で
、現在はそれほど多くのことをしていません
が、これらすべてのリソースを
見て、そのままの状態で段階的に評価されていると思い
ます。 過負荷状態で
本当に強くて言語に堪能になるには、
1回か2回読んだものを深く掘り下げて
50回読む必要があります。
私はこの日本語の料理の本を持っていて、
明らかに料理の語彙を知っています。
まったく別のボール
ゲームで、
鳥焼きのように作るのが好きに
なり、すべての単語を翻訳します。それを
数回行いました。しばらくすると、
それらの単語に精通しているので、すべての単語をマスターできることが
わかります。 だから
、テレビ番組に飛び込むと、何億回も好きだと思うのですが、さまざまなテレビ番組を
見るだけで違いが出ると思います。
私のパトレオンを取っているすべての人に与える一番のヒントは100に同意します。
もちろん
、日本の映画を1本選び、映画の
すべての行を無意識のうちに覚えるまで繰り返し視聴することです。
そう
です、文字通りそうです。100に同意
しますか？
ええと
、あなたも話すインドの言語について話します
、そしてあなたが日本人と持っているかもしれないと思うどんな重複も
そうです私は
あなたが知っているように私は
南インドの言語であるテルグ語を話すと思います
ああ、それは
私が日本人だと思う
のと
非常に似ていますそれは構造がテルグ語のそれと非常に似ている文を言っているときに私たちがここの州で持っている方法とは反対のようですええええと
それから特定の単語は次のようになります
ある程度似ていると思いますが、
語彙と文法によって、テルグ語
を学んでいたときに、
理解しやすくなったと思います。すでにバイリンガルであることを知っている
と思います。 それは間違いなくその面で役立ちました
私
はあなた
の線に沿って何かを言っているあなたのビデオを見たように感じます
最初は
その言語をそのインドの言語で勉強していませんでした
がその後あなたは後でそれを再び拾い始めました
ほんとうに説明するのは、私が生まれたときはテルグが
とても上手だったのですが、日本語を学び始めたときは言語スキルが大幅に低下しました。
今のところ、日本語
はテルグよりもはるかに優れています。
残念ながら、それは私
が日本に恋をしたからです。
まるで私の文化を横に投げたように、私
はあなたが日本人になりたいという段階があることを知っ
ているの
です。
それで
あなたは気がつくような気がしますがええと
それが起こったので今
私はそれ
を受け入れて私の
母国語をもっと習得しようとしていますそれは
あなたが家で話しているような言語でした
あなたの家族ええ、私は
周りを回ることができるようにそれをきちんと話すことができますが、ええと
、私の日本語は間違いなく
それを凌駕していると
思います。
大学
やucberkeleyでさえ、父と話している
と、時にはteluguの代わりに日本語の単語が
飛び出し、それはとても悔しいですが、それは
あなたが完全に没頭したいときに起こる
ことだと思います
あなたはとても若くて、すでに
日本語が上手です。本当に
とても刺激的です。私
は10歳
以上です。10歳以上です。アナーニャよりも年上
です。彼女がこのレベルにいるという事実は
すでに私です。 人口の減少と中国との競争のために、
あなたのビジネスへの関心は今、たくさんの問題に直面しています。
一般的なビジネスへの関心は、一般的な日本人にとって非常に重要だと思います。私
は
、そのような問題全体についてのあなたの考えを聞きたいと思います。
過去の会話では、 将来、ある種
のビジネスをどのように作りたいかについて簡単に話しましたか？それについても少し話していただけれ
ばと思い
ます。
正直なところ、とても
魅力的で、ツイッターは一種の触媒になっています。
特にそのことを変えようとしている多くの日本人と話すことができるようになりました
ええええええそれは興味深いですあなたが日本を見ていることを知っていると思いますそしてそれはクレイジーですが同時にあなたのgdpの点で3番目
です
日本全体の人口は
自分たちに非常に落胆し
ていると思い
ます
過去20年のように過去のすべてが、今では
すべてがソフトウェアに移行し
ているため、遅れをとっています。
そのため、特にTwitterTwitterでdxデジタル変換のような用語を聞くの
はwです。 ここで私は
特にスタートアップをしている人々と話をします
そしてvcsjapanのスタートアップ分野
は本当にエキサイティングであると同時に
多くの問題があります
shosha umのような大企業に行くのです
が、このようなコンセプトのおかげで
、大企業
に行くと報酬が得られ、
残念ながら死ぬまでそこにとどまり
ます。
私たちのようにリスクを冒している人が増える
と、より多くの可能性が
生まれると思います。ベンチャーキャピタルのように十分なスタートアップが得られていないだけ
です。日本の市場の種類を見ると、日本には多くの可能性があります。 日本のメディア出版物のよう
にインターンをしているときにこれをたくさん学んだことを知っています。
彼らはあらゆる種類のアメリカのスタートアップをカバーしていた
ので、私の仕事は[ __ ]で
すべての内部的なことをすることです。
あなたが知っているaneseは、
スプレッドシートに記入するようなものをまとめるのが好きで
、それから私はスタートアップの
ceosと英語で話します、そして私はそれらから多くを学ぶでしょう、
そしてあなたが日本全体で知っている
私の友人のスタートアップのために英語の翻訳のようにやってい
ます
個人的には、将来
は日本と私たちをつなぐビジネスをしたいと思っています。そのよう
なビジネスフォーラム
は、ここ数年の目標であり、
それが何であるかを理解することに近づいてい
ます。 正直なところ、
自分が何をしたいのかわからないので、今
はコンテンツの作成に専念し
ていますが、その可能性は非常に高いと思い
ますが、Twitterで何をしているのかと思います。
とても重要だと思い
ます。あなたが今言ったように、人々がそれらの大企業に行き、
そこにとどまることに熱心である主な理由の1つは、
日本での成功の定義
とあなたが あなたの周りの成功した人々は
あなたが
やりたいことになる大企業に行く人々であることを知っています
そしてすべての学校が同じ
基礎教育システムを持っ
ているならあなたは他に何があるかを理解するのは難しいと思います
オプション
今、私は実際
に日本の将来についても楽観
的です。特に
、私が見たチャンネルの1つで、日本全体
にとって本当に重要だと思うチャンネルの1つ
は、
ええとyoutubeです。 私が完全にそうだと知っている大
ファン大丈夫そうそうそうそうそうそう
彼のチャンネルで彼がしていることは
、あなたがおそらく歴史についての本か経済学についての本か地球温暖化についての本かどうかにかかわらず、彼は一冊の本を取るでしょう
または、会社を始める方法や投資する方法などを教えて
ください。彼
はその本の内容を、
それぞれ約20分の長さの2つのビデオに分解し、
日本の若い
世代を公開します。
同じ意味で、今では公教育システムでは通常見られないものを
youtube
で見直すと、Twitterで行っていることは、過去にもこれについて話し合っ
た完璧な例だと思います。 ツイートとこれは日本語だった
ので、平均的な日本人
と平均的なアメリカ人を連れて行くと、特定の主題を好きになる
と実際には同じ能力を持っているという統計を引用することが非常に重要だと
思います アメリカ人
は、彼らの育成のためにアメリカの文化のために、彼らは
実際よりもそれが得意であると思う
でしょう、そして彼らはより多くの自信を持っているでしょう。
ええと、クラッシュや
燃焼のようなものになります
が、同時に、
その2番目の視点を持つことは非常に価値がある
と思います。
日本人が英語
か日本語か、
外国人が英語か
日本語かを問わず、さまざまな人からの
意見が多ければ多いほど、いわばもっと楽しいと思います。
実際の
ビジネス
目標のようなものおそらくある種のビジネスアイデアのようなもの
それについて話すことが悪いアイデアかどうかはわかりませんが、今あなたの心の
中で跳ね回っているあらゆる種類の詳細は
、私はいつもから明らかに物事を見ています
ビジネス
レンズのように、コンテンツの作成は
私が好きなだけで、それは楽しい
ことです。私はいつも
あなたのことを考えています。どうすればこれを作る
ことができるのか、
受動的な収入を得ることができるのか、
日本のことは、大学時代に知っ
ていたアイデアのように、利益
を生むと思うことは何も考えていなかったようなもの
です。 文化、そして
もう一人は女性のよう
に仕事の場にいるのか、それ
は私がツイートを書いて
いるときに私がたくさん気になっていたこと
や
、日本のビジネスマンとの交流のように何か
があったからかもしれません。 日本でここ数ヶ月の
ようにたくさんの人とたくさんのコーヒーチャットをしたこと
を知っ
ています。正直なところ
、その5％は女性のようで、
他の人は男性の
ようでした。
事業所で設立された、または
VCやスタートアップに入る際のヘッドセットのように
、女性の表現は
非常に低いので
、私がとても
情熱を注いでいる大きな問題は、
日本のように労働時間のよう
に私が
17歳くらいで日本に行っ
て、友達のお父さんが午前12時くらいに家に帰って
、
午前7時に出勤したときのようなショックで、彼にも会いませんでした。
それはちょうど私の心を壊したように私
はそれが正常であると信じることができなかったので
私はそのumにたくさんの論文を書いたので
それらは
私が何かに近づいているときに私の頭の後ろに残る長期的な問題です
が私はしません
今のところ、日本で達成したいビジネスのアイデアは
ありません。それは大きな目標であり
、年を重ねるにつれて、
もう少しおおのようになります。 私は
本当にそれについて何でもできると思いますが、
私は楽観的であり続けようとしてい
ます。なぜなら、その方向への
ステップはあなたが知っている正しいステップ
だと思う
からです。
これを追求したいかどうか
はわかりませんが、日本語で
5分から10分のビデオのように基本的なビジネスコンセプトのように説明するのがわからないような短いyoutubeビデオを
日本語で作成した場合でも、
それはとても興味深いと思います
foから見る あなたからの統治者、特に
インドで生まれた人が自分
で日本語を勉強している州に来ました、
そしてあなたはまだ非常に若いことを知っています
が、すでにこれらの
さまざまな異なる道を
追求してい
ます 私が文字通り彼の本を買ったのは、
彼がすごいと思ったからです。彼はすごいの
です。日本人は
ええとげのじんのよう
にこういうものが好きで、いろいろなものが好きで、
そこにはたくさんの信頼があるような気がします。
彼がテレビの
誰かのような才能のような人
から、非常に
教育的なルートに切り替えたという事実は、多くの希望を生み出し、
私は最後にもっと教育を受けたと感じるビデオを見るだけで希望を得ることができます
絶対
にそうだね。インフルエンサーの領域
のように一般的な多くのこととは対照的に、そうすることは
、私が考える
前にあなたがこれについて言及したと思うが、
そのように 帽子は誰かを
助けることができる教育コンテンツのような価値を生み出します
そして私
はそれを非常にしっかりと信じていますそしてそれ
は私がツイッターでやろうとして
いることですええ私
はあなたがツイッターで
そしておそらく たぶんyoutubeでもチェックしてください
私たちはおそらくすぐに
物事をまとめなければ
ならないでしょうあなたが話したい、または
あなたが知っているとあなたが知っている最後のことはありますか私は
日本語を学ぶときそれは落胆しているように感じるのは簡単だと思います
頭を下げて
、目の前にあるものに集中する必要があると思います。今のように毎日それを取ります。
私が今使っているリソースについて言及したかった
のです。  mいつも日本語を勉強するのは好きではありません
が、私は
日本人と頻繁
に話します。私はum
gishow.orgを
使用して、ラップトップを使用しているときや日本のアプリを使用しているときに、何かを検索する
のが好き
です。  srsを
使用しているのでhcard機能最近はたくさんのフラッシュカードを使っています
日本語が
途切れ途切れ
になっていることがあります
そうそう、その後誰かに会いに行く
と、私はいつものようになります。
そのレベルに戻るような問題はありません。
プラグインしたいものは何でもあります。
私のYouTubeチャンネルを見た人は誰でもそれだと思います。
ええと、今はかなりまばらなように、私は
間違いなくもっとたくさんの
ビデオとtiktokとtwitterを撮影したいと思っ
ています。私はかなり頻繁に更新しようとしてい
ます。日本のヒントを見ることに興味があるなら
、私は私のビデオを持っています
チャンネルだけでなく、ツイッターにも
たくさんのヒントを投稿し
ています。投稿しているコンテンツを読んで、
段落を設定する方法を理解
しているので、一般的には言語のヒントがあります。
ドーガンのスキットをたくさん投稿します
私のチックトックでええと言ったので、それを
チェックしてください私はそれが甘いものの下にリンクされるべきだと思います
私は私の聴衆のほとんど
があなたが将来計画しているすべてのものに非常に興奮しているようです
本当にありがとうございました。とても
光栄です。私もとても興奮しています。私の喜びを心配する必要はありません。
以下のアナーニャのコンテンツをチェックして
ください。